[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my video for the new
spider-man scene that was being filmed
yesterday a ton of people's spidey
senses were off the charts posting about
it asking questions what does this mean
there's a lot of questions that are
being raised by the Easter eggs and
references sony is trying to make inside
the venom verse of movies so we'll break
it all down I'm also doing a movie
ticket giveaway right now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
post all your venom to Morbius
spider-man crossover theories on the
video so we'll just break this down
top-5 style starting with number 5 if
you didn't see the news yesterday a
bunch of pictures started circulating of
a scene with a couple of very prominent
spider-man Easter eggs one of them
confirmed to be on the set of venom two
in the other confirmed to be on the set
of the Morbius movie so if you can't
tell this is obviously an MTA bus and as
it says it's New York City
meaning New York City Transit so the
scene is taking place in New York City
in the bus at Reid's where is spider-man
find out only in the Daily Bugle with a
picture of the earth covered with a
spider's web with a big red question
mark implying that no one knows where on
earth spider-man is hiding out this
spider-man scene was being filmed in
downtown Los Angeles just this past week
the other Easter Egg was Tom Hardy
posting pictures and then deleting them
really quickly from the set of venom two
over in the UK painting Mickey Mouse
Disney ears on all the crew members
referencing crossover with Tom Hollands
spider-man in the MCU as for the first
probably bigger Easter Egg because it's
directly calling out spider-man a lot of
the first people posting about this were
confused about what movie this scene was
taking place in and they assumed it was
venom tube because venom two was also
shooting some second unit stuff near
where the Morbius film was filming in
downtown Los Angeles there's a lot of
different stuff going on for venom two
right now so I'll explain in a second
but then later in the day some more
people saw Jared Leto in Matt Smith
walking through this film set with the
big Spiderman bus ad together getting
ready to film scenes just confirming
that this is taking place in the Morbius
movie and all that Tom Hardy behind the
scenes stuff that's for venom 2 and if
it wasn't clear from the Morbius trailer
Morbius takes place in and around New
York City
venom 2 also takes place in and around
New York City we just haven't seen the
venom 2 trailer yet Andy Serkis the
director
venom - was posting some
behind-the-scenes pictures of them
filming at the orphanage where carnage
grew up in the New York City area so
just confirming that they will be taking
place inside New York City but number
four here's the weird thing though this
isn't just a Spider Man Tom Holland MCU
reference to the ending of spider-man
far from home there are at least three
different references Sony is making with
this Easter Egg zoom and enhance on The
Daily Bugle logo some of you may have
already noticed this The Daily Bugle
logo is the same one from the Tobey
Maguire spider-man movies where the
Daily Bugle was still a newspaper being
run by this version of Jay jonah Jameson
but it's Tom Hollands spider-man from
the MCU that's getting ready to cross
over with the venom burst movies
eventually this is what the Daily Bugle
dotnet logo looks like from the end of
spider-man far from home it's totally
different
so this bus ad is just referencing
spider-man going into hiding after the
spider-man far from home post credits
scene where Jay jonah Jameson outs his
secret identity and leaks Mysterio's
fake doctored footage framing him for
his death but it's also referencing
Tobey Maguire spider-man movies through
the Daily Bugle logo it's the exact same
thing they just did in that Morbius
trailer scene where he walks by the
graffiti of the spider-man suit with the
word murder blaming him for Mysterio's
death referencing the ending of
spider-man far from home but it's Tobey
Maguire spider-man suit into boot it's
actually a picture that's literally copy
pasted from the spider-man ps4 game so
number three now the biggest question
everyone is asking is what is Sony
trying to do here they're clearly
setting up live-action spider-verse
because of what Marvel Sony and Kevin
Feige said about the terms of their new
sharing deal to keep spider-man in the
MCU
but are they mixing and matching all
these Tobey Maguire references in
because they want to say that Morbius of
venom take place in an alternate
universe and like everything that
happened to spider-man in that universe
is 90% the same what happened to MCU
spider-man with a few minor differences
like spider-man into the spider versus a
good example with Peter B Parker almost
everything about his life was the exact
same as ultimate Peter Parker except for
a few things he looked a little bit
different and he was a lot older than
ultimate Peter Parker the other big
theory I've seen people talking about is
that Sony wanted to reference future Tom
Hollands spider-man crossover but they
just slapped a lot of these Easter eggs
together at the last minute without
assuming that fans would spend hours
analyzing them and noticing the
inconsistencies like why use all the
Tobey Maguire stuff if it's gonna be Tom
Hollands showing up on screen with
spider-man actually cameos in a scene in
why use a screen grab from the
spider-man ps4 game does the spider-man
ps4 game exist in this universe what's
going on so number two the Michael
Keaton vulture cameo scene and the
Morbius trailer is the one thing I think
at all of this that helps it make sense
it confirms the link to Tom Hollands
spider-man from the MCU even if the
earth that Morbius and venom takes place
on winds up being an alternate universe
it's still Tom Hollands spider-man
jumping between universes as Kevin Feige
put it a few months ago when they were
working out all that Sony marble drama
because the only reason they would pay
Michael Keaton millions of dollars to
show up for five minutes of screen time
in the Morbius movie is so that everyone
sitting in the theater who might not be
spider-man experts will look at him and
understand the MCU spider-man connection
from spider-man homecoming that's why
he's wearing the exact same white prison
jumpsuit from the spider-man homecoming
post-credit scene it's on our little
spider you have to remember that not
everybody looks at Easter eggs this way
so they're making a lot of these movies
for a very general audience so they'll
see Michael Keaton and go oh he's the
guy from the spider-man homecoming movie
so that means it's connected to that the
other big reason to drop all that money
on a Michael Keaton cameo because he is
not cheap is to set up future sinister
six movie just tease what's going on
with those characters because Sony
definitely wants to make another
sinister six movie that becomes a whole
other thing because you wonder will
Marvel be involved in making a sinister
six movie or will that just be Sony
trying to make that will that be its own
franchise there's only one or two other
big characters I would want them to
introduce the Craven truck was spotted
on the set of Morbius so they're teasing
all the spider-man stuff they're clearly
also trying to tease Kraven as another
big villain they're getting ready to
introduce but since Doctor Octopus was
the original founder of the comic book
sinister six team the first version of
the team I don't know how you could make
a team without him somehow so hopefully
we'll see some Doctor Octopus in the
spider-man movies in the next couple of
years I also kind of think part of the
reason they're using the Tobey Maguire
spider-man suit in low
and all this is because Marvel and Sony
only just figured out what they're
comfortable with in terms of putting MCU
stuff inside the Sony movies still very
early days and Sony needed to put
something in their trailer in these
pickup scenes so they just said well we
don't want to risk getting sued by
Marvel and Disney down the road but we
need to film this right now so we'll
just use our spider-man suit from our
movie trilogy in our game studio because
Sony owns the game studio that made
spider-man ps4 and use it to let people
know that spider-man exists in these
movies and we'll see him eventually so
early theory I think this is a Spider
Man into the spider-verse style
situation where a couple minor details
of spider-man's history in the movies
are a little bit different in an
alternate reality like in this reality
The Daily Bugle is still newspaper
instead of a website and Jay jonah
Jameson on Venom's earth looks like this
instead of like this MCU version of Jay
jonah Jameson from the ending of
spider-man far from home thanks for
watching don't forget to Like and
subscribe so down the road Sony can say
that this is connected to all the MCU
spider-man stuff but also Kevin Feige
and Marvel can say technically the venom
stuff isn't happening inside the MCU but
number one WTF for those of you seeing
all these Tobey Maguire spider-man
Easter eggs and references and are
asking if he would ever come back for a
movie yes I totally think it's possible
Sony could have worked out a deal for
eventual spider-verse level cameo scenes
how do we press this how do we make it
more exciting more fun how do we evolve
the character and make it a rich story
and how do I make it interesting for
myself to go and do something else but
for now the main version of spider-man
that we'll see when we see spider-man
crossing over with venom in Morbius and
any other sinister six characters in the
Sony movies will be Tom hones spider-man
as for venom - when Tom Hardy posting
pictures of himself dressed up like MCU
spider-man in the iron spider suit
that's Tom Hardy wearing that suit he
posted and then deleted this from his
Instagram account a while ago painting
all the Disney ears on the crew members
from venom - it's just him saying yes
we're gonna be doing some spider-man
stuff in our movie but it doesn't really
say what that's going to look like venom
2 takes place in and around New York
City just like the Morbius movies so
it's possible all their Spiderman
references and easter eggs will be just
like the Morbius trailer there have been
rumors that Sony has been trying to lock
down Tom Holland
for a deal to cameo in venom - I don't
know if that'd be a post-credits scene
but it's just a rumor right now so it's
not confirmed to be true I think the
biggest question now though is what
they're gonna do when Tom Holland
actually crosses over into the movies
will he literally fall through a portal
into another world or another reality
with these venom characters or will he
just show up in that movie and they'll
pretend like he's always been there and
just not say anything about Iron Man or
the Avengers post all your theories in
the comments below how do you think
they'll explain Tom Holland showing up
if they have so many of these Easter
eggs that are making Tobey Maguire
spider-man references they just finished
filming principal photography on venom
two yesterday the movies being released
in October so the first venom 2 trailer
will probably be released in the next
month or two around the Black Widow
movie if not sooner so hopefully there's
some Morbius trailer style scene in the
venom 2 trailer with a direct spider-man
reference to just clarify what's going
on with spider-man inside the Sony
movies let me know if there's any
special videos that you want me to do
next
everyone click here for my new Avengers
infinity Saga deleted scene and click
here for my new Marvel phase 4 trailer
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome this is the way